oh wait a second there's a sick tactic
here
oh my gosh but it doesn't quite work oh
this would have been a total and
complete oh wait it might actually work
wait I gotta calculate
[Music]
okay let's go let me get the white
pieces no we got the black pieces
against meridad from Iran
and
we get another Sicilian this speedrun
has been defined by just the and there
we go again I mean nobody goes into the
open Sicilian and this has been very
eye-opening even at this level I mean
it's very high level people are still
playing all sorts of Sidelines Bishop C4
immediately is
a move that we faced in a slightly
different mood order we have faced
Knight F3 Knight C6 and there a ton of
people earlier on in the speedrun have
gone Bishop C4 as we know it's a
completely innocuous move basically
playing the Italian against the Sicilian
uh is not really going to cut it and the
main reason why is concerned with our
ability to play E6 right why is the
bishop developed here when black plays
E5 wants to make contact with the F7
Pawn but when we have the capacity to
play E6 and shut this bishop out the
move makes very little sense but we
don't need to play E6 immediately
White's not threatening Bishop takes F7
so first I think it's a good idea to
bring our Knight out
and in response to Knight F3 okay A3 so
clearly this this might be some sort of
preparation but I highly doubt that it
is in any case the best way to respond
to such play is to follow principles to
a t right if you follow principles and
you develop your pieces there's only so
much that your opponent can do to you so
what I would propose here is the
simplest possible approach just bring
the other night out to F6 and white
can't even play E5 because that square
is developed defended that's why we
played Knight C6 first Knight C3 okay
now
there's a couple of possible approaches
some of you might be attracted to the
center fork trick which I've talked at
length about Knight takes E4 Knight
takes E4 and then you win back the minor
piece with D5 which is by the way a
typical trick in this variation of the
Sicilian but here specifically I think
it might be a little bit premature
um and it and it leads to unnecessary
complications so I think a simpler
approach is just to play the movie six
now and of course we are preparing to
expand in the center with D5 and the
idea of Knight takes E4 does not go
anywhere we can still very much apply
that idea it just depends on how white
develops okay Bishop A2 now of course we
don't have the the center fork trick
anymore but I think that we should
continue calmly expanding in the center
there's there's many ways that you can
play a position like this and oftentimes
it's you know a matter of taste you
don't have to go D5 because in the
Sicilian you're not expected to occupy
the center with your pawns you could
even go D6 you could play this in a more
conventionally sicilian-esque type of
way then white will be likely to play
Knight F3 and ultimately white could
play the move d4 and you transpose back
into some sort of Sicilian or white just
has this terrible Bishop on A2 that's
biting on granite but in this speedrun
we're trying to play principal chess
we're trying to actively punish our
opponents and go for the advantage when
we're facing a second or third string
opening and so that of course involves
playing the move D5 and grabbing control
of the center and trying to take it to
our opponent it takes we take back with
a pawn and we already have a very
pleasant pleasant position I I wouldn't
say that black is much better maybe
slightly better just because we have
better control of the center but that's
about it right White's position is still
Ultra solid and there's no need for us
to
you know to overdo it Knight F3 okay so
typically the priority is to develop our
King side because well because our King
is in the center and with his last move
white has signaled a Readiness to Castle
quickly and put a rook on E1 we don't
want our King in the center when that
happens but there's a subtlety to keep
in mind which is that white also signals
his intent to play D4 and the move d4
may not seem like a big deal but if you
just nonchalantly Sleepwalk into
cd494 well then you get an iqp structure
where white controls the square in front
of it and you justify the placement of
this bishop which is of course now aimed
at the D5 Pawn if that pawn were to
become isolated that might be a bigger
problem so the answer could be to play
D4 ourselves but that also has the very
serious drawback of expanding the
diagonal for the bishop so I think D4 is
a little bit overzealous how else can we
prevent white from playing D4 well
there's a developing move that we could
make that quote unquote violates you
know the rule about what we prioritize
and yet it might be the most active way
to stop D4 I'm talking about Bishop C8
to G4
and I think that we're going to try this
move out
and if White Castles in this position
then we can play Bishop E7 and white can
put a rook on E1 but that's not gonna
hurt us because it's not going to be a
check anymore we could also of course
play Knight to D4 but Knight D4 is
premature and in response to Knight D4
white has this weird move Queen to E1
check this is a a worthy trick to know
actually you should remember this in
certain situations when you have the
bishop on G4 and the Knight on D4 Queen
E1 check gets out of the pin with a
check and if you were to block the check
then why you can safely take on D4 and
ruin our structure so instead of you
know trying to jump the gun with Knight
T4 let's play it safe and simple with
Bishop to E7
now Knight D4 is a much more serious
threat so our opponent plays H3 okay
fine
and where are we gonna go with the
bishop there is a little bit of an issue
that we at least need to calculate out
which is that if we play Bishop H5 which
is what I want to play White does have
the possibility of G4
and when we drop our Bishop to G6 white
can advance the pawn all the way to G5
and once the Knight moves away probably
to E4 the D5 Pawn can be lost the white
can capture that pawn with either the
Knight or the bishop because we're going
to lose a defender on that pawn but just
intuitively if white Bush's G4 and G5
his King is going to be in complete and
total shambles there is just no way that
that can possibly justify a measly Pawn
in the center and this is something I've
talked about in the last few speedrun
games where at this level you just have
to release your fear of giving up pawns
right minor material sacrifices are just
a normal part of the game and you should
do it essentially without batting an eye
so we're gonna go Bishop H5 and our
opponent goes for the line now so the
sack on G4 here is interesting and
should be taken very seriously but I
don't think it works although we should
investigate it for a little while Knight
takes G4 HG Bishop takes G4 the problem
is that white takes on D5 there with
bishop and simultaneously defends the
Knight on F3 taking the sting out of the
move Knight D4 so I'm not gonna spend
too much time on it let's go Bishop G6
let's see what mayor died comes up with
in this position
okay D3 so our opponent kind of fakes us
out a little bit and then plays D3
this of course does give us if we so
desire the opportunity to play H6 and
prevent white from playing G5 or at
least make it
futile okay so we can play H6
we can ignore the threat of G5 and just
Castle kingside which is of course the
preferable thing to do but then after G5
already with with the pawn on D3 what
that means is we don't have the E4 we
can't jump to E4 with the Knight so in
that case we're gonna have to drop the
Knight back down to D7 then white takes
on D5 still I think black has good
compensation for the pawn but I'm not as
convinced in the rectitude of this
approach I actually like the move H6
here I think it's a it's a tempo right
so we're using a Tempo but we're really
taking the heat off of the D5 Pawn which
I think is pretty important yeah we
could also play D4 but I'm really I'm
hesitant to play this move because it
opens up the bishop for some reason I
have like a mental block
about the move d4 also it helps the
Knight get back to E2 and then the
Knight could Shuffle over to F4
and with the diagonal open the bishop on
G6 would come under some fire so okay
let's speed up a little bit here our
opponent's playing instantly so let's
Castle
yeah I think black is doing a okay here
and of course again at the present
moment we're not in a position to
exploit the weakness of White's King
side that is true but it's all about the
long-term weakness My Hope Is that once
we get you know the wheels turning and
we play a move like Queen D7 ultimately
white is going to pay the price
hopefully a steep price for creating
this permanent weakness on the king side
you know certain things have to be
appreciated in the long run yes
currently we don't have the Machinery to
exploit these weaknesses that's true
I'm I'm the physician isn't quite as
good as I was hoping it would be given
what our opponent played so definitely
you know some opening investigation will
open
will open my eyes and hopefully open
yours as well Bishop F4 okay so white
develops their pieces let's consider
the options here so the sort of plain
vanilla move is Queen up to D7 right
because it connects the Rooks and you
know it aims at the G4 Pawn so maybe it
sets up some potential Knight takes you
for ideas that's that's one option the
queen has to stay pegged to the D5 Pawn
so the move Queen B6 here I don't like
because it gives up D5
um what are the other options well we
could try to like remove this bishop
with Bishop to D6 that's another very
reasonable move I think and we still
have the move d4
which is sort of hanging in the air it's
always a possibility the Knight drops
back to E2 and the advantage of playing
D4 here is that for me too the Knight
cannot currently access F4 because The
Bishop's there but still I don't like D4
from a positional standpoint I think
we'll play that move only if we
absolutely have to
now let me think about this for for a
hot second
because our opponent wants to go like 95
that's a nasty idea
because when 95 happens
as a result of the trade the bishop
lands on E5 and then our D5 Pawn starts
coming under serious fire because white
will threaten
Bishop takes F6 and then potentially
Knight takes D5 so that's something we
have to address I think I figured out a
way to do that though let's play Queen
D7
let's start with this move
and first of all we need to
white needs to put his cards on the
table
so again Queen D7 connects the Rooks and
prepares to bring the Rooks into the
center Rook 88 and Rook fe8 would be two
moves I would definitely want to play if
given the opportunity
why is our Bishop on G6 well I would
love for our Bishop to be on E6 here
don't get me wrong but remember when
white played H3 we could have dropped
back at this point to E6 but this would
defeat the purpose of us playing Bishop
G4 which was to prevent white from
playing D4 or to induce this massive
weakness on the king side so here white
could have played D4 but this is with
the King as weak as it is this is a
completely different story
but we'll Analyze That more after the
game
so with white here I would probably play
like Queen D2 I would probably keep the
tension but a lot of players in this
rating range they have a harder time
when you reach the Early Middle game to
like to keep the tension to make these
slower moves that toss the ball back
back into your opponent's court for a GM
those kinds of moves are second nature
but hopefully I've laid out our next few
moves assuming that our opponent doesn't
play something like Knight E5 which I'm
a little bit worried but Bishop G3 okay
so whites simply keeps the tension as
well Bishop G3 is a bit of an empty move
I think I don't see exactly what it does
I think it gives us an opportunity to
keep working on our position keep
improving I think we'll start that
process with Rook a to d8 because I
really really want some more eyes on the
D5 Pawn this is a big Pawn we don't want
to lose it let's make sure that it's
really well protected I think this will
pay off positively later down the line
when you know we get more head-to-head
contact with white knight E2 yeah so our
opponent is initiating a really
impressive maneuver actually with Knight
to F4 yeah Bishop g392 Knight F4 is like
super high level chess how do we address
that idea well let's think about this
okay so there's a couple of
considerations that I have here
I think that we should start with a sort
of I would call this a semi-propylactic
move because Knight F4 does in fact
threaten to take the bishop on G6 and I
say threaten in air quotes because it's
not literally a thread but we definitely
don't want
to ruin the king side structure that
would also open up the diagonal for the
bishop it should be self-evident why you
don't want to give the bishop up on G6
so I'd like to start with the move
Bishop to H7 just tucking the bishop
away on a safer square and then after
Knight F4 we have a Tempo that we can
use to do basically whatever we want
what do we want to achieve here well we
still have the move Rook F to E8 which
is kind of in our pockets there's a
bigger fish to fry here which is the
fact that this bishop is starting to
annoy the heck out of me this bishop is
becoming a big problem and now that the
Knight has gotten to F4 white is
exerting even more serious pressure on
D5 so I'd like to mitigate or at least
address that problem I don't want to do
that by playing G5 that creates a huge
weakness of our own are there any
methods that exist to shut this bishop
down to somehow relieve the pressure on
the D5 Pawn well there is one idea that
I had and I had this idea the moment
that white moved the Knight away from C3
the moment the Knight moved on way here
I had this idea to play B5 and then try
to shove the pawn down to C4 and build
up a little Pawn chain to shut this
bishop out on A2
yeah so we played B5 and also this grabs
some space on the queen side so as a
standalone idea it's good also when we
play C4 our Bishop on H7 finally gets
something to do like it not much but we
start exerting a little bit of pressure
on the D3 Pawn
I think this is a really really nice
idea B5 and C4 to shut the bishop on A2
down there is also a slightly concerning
possibility of G5 which I didn't take
that seriously until like two seconds
ago
I still don't think it's that dangerous
for us but it's something to keep in
mind
if white plays G5
then we probably take white takes back
with the Knight and we can preserve the
bishop with Bishop F5 Queen D2 okay fine
so our opponent continues to improve his
position and we will continue to improve
ours I don't see a reason for us to
refrain from the move C4 let's go for it
we have to keep some time on our clocks
yeah so we've locked White's Bishop in
which is some progress now I feel like
we can breathe a little bit easier
although obviously we have to watch out
for D take C4 because the bishop on E7
The Rook is making contact with it so
there's some tension in the center we
have to make sure that after DC we have
the capacity to recapture probably with
the d-pawn probably with the Deep Pawn
because taking back what the B Pawn
would leave us with a weakness in the
center on D5
on the other hand DC is a big concession
because it gives away the E4 square that
we can use as a Outpost for a night Rook
81 okay
so now I think it's time for us to
continue improving and you know crossing
our T's and dotting our eyes
and there's multiple ways that we can do
that I like the look of Bishop E7 to D6
here in a weird way just getting the
bishop out of the line of fire of the
rook and aiming at the Knight but of
course I also like Rook F to E8 which is
the move that we've been planning to
play for a while
let me think about this first our
opponent is playing phenomenally so this
is not going to be an easy game
I'm going to take a moment to think here
okay actually there's a third thing that
we can consider doing which is moving
the queen away
so that the Rook x-rays whites Queen
also an interesting thought something
like Queen to C8 here Queen to B7 could
be worth investigating as well
actually I quite like the look of Queen
C8 yeah I like the look of Queen C8 here
because it it takes the sting out of the
move D takes C4 then we can recapture
with the d-pawn and where groovy we're
chilling because the Rook is attacking
the queen
also I was unhappy with the placement of
the queen here because it in certain
lines 95 comes with Tempo and I don't
want 95 to come with tempo so we're
going to tuck the queen away on a
somewhat more protected Square let's see
what our opponent comes up with now
yeah Bishop C5 also would have been
would have been very feasible yum yeah
Bishop C5 would be a serviceable move
also and that might be the move we play
next we want white to play D4 if white
can play if I plays D4 here we're like
unbelievably happy because we get the E4
square and white no longer has any
pressure in the center and then whites
of Queen and Rook look dumb so it's a
battle over who flinches first in the
center that's ultimately what the battle
is revolving around and while this
tension in the center is occurring we're
like in a stalemate in the center we're
both trying to jostle for position and
improve the placement of our pieces
so that when the center does open up
which is eventually going to happen
tension can exist forever we will see
whose Army is better prepared to deal
with the consequences I like these types
of games because they really expand your
positional thinking and they're some of
the most complex positions that exist in
chess when the center is so undefined in
in this kind of way
um it really forces you to appreciate
how your entire Army collaborates and
works
so this is where you develop your
thinking
the rookie 2 is probably an attempt to
double Rooks on the D file
now they're oh wait a second there's a
sick tactic here
oh my gosh but it doesn't quite work oh
this would have been a total and
complete
wait it might actually work
wait I gotta calculate
does anybody see what I'm talking about
yeah 94 I think 94 might work
94 Pawn takes Pawn takes
so that's why we played Queen C8 also
then white has the move Knight C5 so
there are some incredibly complicated
calculations there I won't I will spare
you the sort of verbal lines until after
the game because those positions are
hard to visualize
our opponent might go for this line
though that was the problem line the
reason I thought this doesn't work is
after d-e-d-e white can block the attack
on the queen with Knight F4 to D5
hopefully everybody kind of can
visualize that move and in that
resulting position if we play e takes F3
then white has Rook takes Bishop on E7
and 97-97 check is a four king h8 Knight
C8 Rook D5 Rook D5 Rook C8 but at the
end black is down a minor piece so after
d-e-d-e Knight D5 I found a follow-up
tactic that exploits the undefended
nature of the Rook on D1
does anybody see that tactic I mean I
can ask you why our opponent is thinking
in this position after d-e-d-e95 there
is a a move that obviates the need for
all of that calculation it's a simple
idea actually very nice alph chess you
deserve a sub
d-e-d-e-95 Rook takes D5 drawing in the
queen and then pinning it with Rook to
d8 okay it's a total moot point our
opponent doesn't do it but our opponent
has made a very serious concession he's
allowed us to take the bishop on G3 by
eliminating the bishop we're loosening
some of the glue that holds White's
position together the bishop was what I
would call a glue piece and without it
this this has to signify progress for us
now we can't rest on our Laurels because
Rook takes E7 is now a threat that gives
away two pieces for a rook so we need to
do something with this bishop where
should we move it well we can move in a
bunch of places I like the square F6 the
only problem is then it might run into
some Knight H5 shenanigans
so that could be a bit of an issue
Bishop did D6 looks pretty good actually
I like the look of Bishop D6 yeah let's
play Bishop D6
Let's Play Bishop D6
which is the square that we've been
talking about earlier and and we're
pressuring the Knight on F4 and but
tactics here are important Knight takes
D5
The Rook x-rays the Knight so I believe
there's Bishop C5 check
there to justify this move
and the Knight could block there with
Knight E3 but then we just play C takes
d3c takes D3 and we can take again on D3
and black gets a huge initiative we want
to open up the board now that we have
the bishop pair and now that white has
this terrible piece on A2
okay D4
all right so this is more good news for
us because now the bishop is at least
temporarily out of the game although it
could rejoin the game via B1 and then
white could play C3 and open up the
bishop but we that gives us a couple of
Tempe where we have an extra man on the
field
what do we want to achieve here well we
could take the Knight on F4 but I don't
really understand why this trade favors
us and it corrects white spawn structure
free visit to the orthodontist
Queen C7 walks into Knight takes D5
because then the queen is hanging maybe
Queen B8 is an interesting move Queen B8
actually is a very high level move
Queen B8 the other move that I like here
is Rook F to E8 just basically
contesting the E file and saying hey
you're not having the e-file all to
yourself
but queen bee it is a is a devilish
little move
Queen B8 is a devilish move I like I
like Queen B8
it's a it's it's a move that has a
little bit more Pizzazz you know because
you're building up the battery on the
Knight and of course the tactics here
are Knight takes D5 runs into Bishop
takes G3
and that's a double attack because then
the queen is attacked and the Knight on
D5 is attacked and notice also that the
E7 square is defended by our Knight so
97 check is never going to be a valid
intermezzo
so hopefully that explains why Knight
takes D5 doesn't work
we're we are now threatening to take
twice on F4 so the only way that I see
for white to defend well there's two
there's Queen to D2 then there's the
move I'm slightly more afraid of
hopefully our opponent doesn't play it
and the reason I'm more afraid of it is
because I think I underestimated it
but we'll see we'll see what our
opponent does
um what I'm hoping for is Queen to D2
and that's what happens there was also
the move Knight to E5 which got me a
little bit worried so what the great
thing about Queen to D2 is that it puts
the queen on the D2 Square okay that
means there's a move which we could have
also played here but here it was less
effective there was this move Bishop E4
but it would have run into Knight D2
although now I realize that there we can
play Knight 64 but long story short now
we can play Bishop E4 and that Bishop is
very very safe in the center and we're
starting to really massage some of these
weak squares in White's territory we're
making progress
we're making progress we're getting a
little low on time but I I will speed up
if things get down to like a Time
scramble the next few moves are
crucially important so let's see if we
can invest some time
and then once once we get down to a Time
scramble I will speed up
I mean I'm also legitimately thinking
about what to do
no G5 is is
a move that has to be played with your
tremendous degree of caution because it
creates get just massive holes on the
king side Rook F2
it's exactly what I was slightly
concerned about let's see
what can we do here we need to continue
accumulating we need to improve our
position okay G5 actually does make some
sense but after Knight H5 Bishop G3 that
gets very tactical and we're low on time
so I don't really want to go for that
I mean maybe G5 is good but it's I can't
evaluate it it's too hard to evaluate
okay so B4 is an option here
a takes B4
but that's a bit of a dead end because
Knight before Bishop B1 maybe we just
play A5 and we improve our position
maybe we go Rook fe1
yeah let's go work Fe let's let's make a
neutral move for now just to improve our
position
kinds of moves when you start getting
low on time you have to be comfortable
to sort of like defaulting to moves like
this you just have to sense when to play
them okay C3 grade move our opponent
this intends Bishop B1 now I had a very
cool idea
I think a very cool idea okay we can
play A5 and B4 that's one cool idea
actually beef A5 and B4 looks sexy
yeah let's go let's go Queen side attack
and this is the classic Queen side
attack everybody or most people in the
chat should be familiar we just push A5
and B4 and we try to smash through the
queen side
just in the nick of time while the
Bishop is still sort of holding the fort
which is not going to be the case for
very long
okay so this A5 before idea is like
Ultra standard there's a tactical detail
here that's very important if white
takes on e4 ask yourself what we're
going to recapture with and why
and the the answer is the pun because
after de4 the Knight hangs and E3 with a
fork against the queen and the Rook
loses material for white
and how did I see that well anytime
Queen and Rook are in forkable spots
right one square away on the same rank
then you have to be aware of the role of
Pawn Forks if it was our move what what
are we actually threatening here we're
not really threatening BC
because BC there's Queen takes C3 we're
threatening ba
because ba white can't take back because
the bishop on B1 simply hangs don't
forget about the queen that we
put on bien and white misses it I think
King G2 is panic
I think it's panic
and I think after ba we have finally
broken through at least the initial
shell of White's defense there's plenty
of work to do this is just a pawn for
the time being
but once we take that pawn White's whole
structure on the queen side starts to
collapse
so what's going on in this position well
our Bishop is doing a just an amazing
job of holding everything together it
can't be captured okay so our and this
is always what happens
right at some point
and I've talked about this kind of type
of game I would call this like a a game
Arc
where somebody plays Super well super
well super well you keep putting
pressure and putting pressure and the
collapse happens in like one or two
moves right at a GM level
a lot of the wins are over the course of
like 20 30 moves and there's like tiny
inaccuracies at this level we still see
that when you put a certain amount of
pressure on people they just they'll
make like two huge blunders in a row
which is essentially what happened here
although white was already worse okay
what do we take with let's be let's be
disciplined here there's two ways to win
there's one slightly fancy fancy way the
the other is the working man's approach
the working man's approach is just to
play Bishop takes E5 and that's what
we're gonna do because the pawn the
bishop cannot be recaptured White's
probably gonna play ba and then we have
a very pretty follow-up tactic that
simply ends the game
if white plays ba okay let's see who can
find it there are several ways to
execute this tactic you can carry it out
in two different ways but one is more
forcing than the other yeah double Jared
found the second one
so a lot of you guys are seeing Bishop
takes D4 and E3 but one piece of advice
which is just a no-brainer when you have
a two move tactical sequence right a
tactical sequence you should always test
what happens if you switch up the move
order because sometimes you'll just find
that it's a much better much cleaner
execution and in this case I think it is
Bishop E3 is more forcing right it's
forcing Queen E3 then Bishop takes D4
it's easy to see that we are winning
overwhelming amounts of material
yeah E3 Bishop takes D4 attacking the
queen two different ways the bishop is
defended by the Knight and by The Rook
which is important
because if white takes the bishop with
the pawn then obviously white loses the
Queen White takes with the queen then
white also loses the queen
that's it the game is over
okay so again we want to be super
clinical at this level so there is a
move here that very few people would
play and yet it is I think the best move
because if you take the Rook then you
give white a choice of minor pieces to
recapture it doesn't freaking matter
we're up a rook but again let's build
good habits okay don't overthink it
rookie three blunders the Knight on C6
and then you don't have anything to
capture in return
okay instead you can make a different
type of Intermezzo which is Knight c6e5
hit the queen first then take on F2 and
you will be able to keep your knight
that can then jump into D3 with decisive
effect
and 95 is just that cherry on top kind
of move Precision is something that you
don't want to overdo
so if you see a win go for it but
you know we're getting to a 2000 level
where moves like 95 are important to win
winning games fast and efficiently
this was an interesting opening though I
I actually don't know the best way to
play against this like I've seen people
play this before Bishop C4 and A3 I know
it's a obscure line but this is where
the Learning Happens see I don't know
the theory of that line either so we use
the engine
and we use the game database and we
figure things out
okay Queen E4 thankfully our opponent is
installing out okay now we obviously
take the Rook on F2
Now The Rook on D1 is hanging and if
white captures it then we play Queen
takes d8 in order to keep the X-ray
against White's Queen alive right we
take with the queen not with the Rook so
that if white plays King takes F2 we
have actually a choice of discover
checks that we can deliver in order to
win the White Queen
this is a resign time I think for our
opponent
there we go very nice thank you
yeah that was nice
I'm gonna pull up chess base actually I
already have it open
and uh we're gonna take a quick look at
this particular mover now I want to
remind you of what we have faced in the
past what we have faced in the past is
the battler attack the more traditional
version of it which is to start with
Knight F3 then to play Bishop C4 I even
taught this to Charlie and here if I
remember correctly
um the move that I looked at was E6
castles and Knight F6 this is the move
order that we've looked at and then if
white plays rookie one there's the
center fork trick where you take on e4
and play D5 and black is fine if white
plays E5 then you go Knight G4 rookie
one and D6 I'm pretty sure I remember
looking at this position and thinking
that black is doing great
but this move order is a little bit
different so Knight C6 has to be good
and now A3
now A3 okay so according to the engine
Knight F6 is fine
Knight C3
okay interesting and E6 is best
so we played this accurately E6 is best
Bishop A2
D5 is best
okay so we didn't play this too badly e
d e d Knight F3 okay so this is
interesting Bishop G4 is good
but according to the engine the best
move is in fact to play D4
ha oh and there's a very concrete detail
that I didn't foresee which is that
after 92 who can tell me let's see if
anybody can figure out the best move for
black here the fact that I'm already
asking you is like
a hint which basically means it's
something that's not just like oh Bishop
D6 there's something you have to do
and actually this is an idea which
occurs in the jabala London I should
yeah D3
but here's the thing after CD most
people I think would just automatically
take on D3 that's not the point
that is actually a very bad move that
that is counter to the point which is
that you want these pawns to bury
White's minor pieces to make it very
difficult for him to develop the minor
pieces what do you do with that time
well with the time that you now have you
try to apply very rapid pressure on
White's vulnerable King side so the best
move here after D3 CD is to play now
Bishop G4
and put pressure on the Knight on F3 and
black white is in trouble here
so let's say white plays Knight E2 to G3
after Bishop D6 white is buried this is
a miserable miserable position
because White's Bishop on C1 is never
getting out
and if white plays H3 it's -4 takes
takes now you stick the knight in the
center
Queen D1
okay let's say queen B7 at least wait
suffers for the pawn
now Bishop G3
FG
and you sack another Pawn
so you give up a seven as well
but now you just go after White's King
92 check
and uh King H2 is forced to defend G3
and just Queen to D6 oh and this is this
is so sexy after Rook F3 who can find
the crushing move this is really really
pretty
yeah Knight G4 I mean Anastasia is made
look at that and look at my structure
and this tells you all you have to know
and if King H1 then the winning move is
Queen D4 because you're aiming at the
g1s and what is the underlying problem
in this entire sequence it's the fact of
why it's Queen side is not playing and
white can't defend all these squares
Rook f193 is made you could even do this
I mean you don't deliver a mate like
this every day
so that I mean we went very far
obviously that line is unlikely but this
gives you a flavor of how dangerous this
idea can be and this idea exists also in
the jababa London there's a line in the
jabalon I actually had a for those
watching on YouTube I had a Blitz game
in this line today just before I started
the speedrun Stream So in the C5
variation of the jababa London and the
course link is in the description there
is a line where black plays CD Queen D4
Knight D7 and Knight C6 Bishop B5 Bishop
D7 takes takes E5 Knight D7 so in this
position it's the same type of idea what
does black want well black wants to play
E6 and develop the dark squared Bishop
so what do we do we play E6 ourselves
F take C6 and we pile up on this E5
Square to make it very difficult for
black to bring out to bring out his dark
squared Bishop now black can try to
dislodge white screen from D4 and the
line goes on Queen D2 black can fiancaro
the bishop but fiancadoing it is just
not as good and this Pawn structure in
the center is remarkably weak your white
is supposed to Castle Queen side and
play Rook H1 and white gets a great
position lots of different openings
where this idea is applied so the lesson
is the move is D4 followed by D3 sorry
followed by Bishop two G4
now what else do we want to explore here
I guess according to the computer
Queen E2 check is slightly better than
Knight E2 because what this does is it
allows White's Knight to get to E4
but still we play T3 it's still we play
this move
CD
actually no Knight F6 check black will
start with
GF so we don't mind damaging our
structure a little bit okay C takes D3
and now Apparently after Bishop G4 still
has huge problems for white because
Knight D4 is coming
and this queen is in trouble and if
white plays Queen to E4 then we simply
defend the bishop and we castle
queenside and again white is playing
without his Queen side so white is
supposed to play like this
take with the queen rather than with the
pawn which is not easy to do by the way
and still takes takes Bishop G4 it's
minus over plus Bishop D5 is probably
the human move and you're just Castle
Queen side you don't give a about pawns
here we're happy to give them up
if the engine move here is funny engine
just gives King C7 engine doesn't give a
sh
it's just like I'm just improving my
position because white is paralyzed this
is the concept A lot of humans don't
fully understand it's like paralysis the
fact that white white can try B3
now apparently the winning move is this
oh my God this is amazing Rook hf8
Bishop C4 B5
who can tell me the idea of the move B5
this wins the game by the way
I mean the engine's analyzing of the
engine is so fun Bishop F3
GF and Knight D4 and this is the double
attack you're forking a fork as I like
to say because the bishop is hanging as
is the fork on C2 white loses a rook
so why you can't even play B3 defend
ghetto the bishop otherwise you play
Bishop F3 and stick the Knight on D4 so
as you're watching this especially if
you're newer to chess of course the
actual opening analysis is important
because as a sicilian player you should
know this
but because it's quite rare there's also
takeaways when it comes to typical ideas
and here we see a good example of how
pawn count is totally meaningless in
certain situations so the move is D4 but
we played Bishop G4 which I think is
second best according to the engine but
after White Castles here I think I made
a serious inaccuracy yeah Bishop B7
allows H3 and G4 and now white gets very
active so the best move here was again
to play D4
again to play T4 and after rookie one
check black is only slightly better here
because white has this trick with rookie
1 and Knight E4
but still D3
and practically speaking it's very
unpleasant for white white can actually
take this Pawn
DC okay things get very messy here
Bishop F3 GF
now you're supposed to bring the rook in
to C8
but this threat of Knight D4 I mean
White's position is still very very very
unpleasant so still you played D3
this is the central idea that I failed
to properly grasp fail to appreciate
instead
I miss the opportunity and why I was
able to drive in the pawn of G4 and
start pressuring the D5 Pawn after
blackplay's D4 asks forbidden Groot is
there Bishop takes F7 Shenanigans so I
don't know where you meant
uh the answer is no
if you play it here in Bishop F7 doesn't
do anything it's just two checks and you
can even play King G6 I had a speeder in
game like this actually where our
opponents sacked prematurely and upside
why there's no pieces in the attack or
King G8 the king is perfectly safe
versus in this position no there's still
no Bishop F7 Shenanigans remember this
trick only works when the bishop on G4
is undefended remember that when the
bishop is defended it doesn't work
because the bishop is defended so the
answer is no
is h3g4 really that good for white yeah
I think black is preferable here but I
would say the position is closer to
equal than to an advantage to Black okay
we had another question and that D4 line
after Knight G3 can why do Knight E5
okay so let's see and that D4 line
Knight G3 Bishop D6
no I mean 95 never works because the
queen is pinned and Bishop F7 is never
made so no no none of that kind of stuff
is working here
my only question is after you played 94
and they win Queen E1 why Knight takes
G3
instead of Knight G5 okay so that's in
the game
and we'll get to that moment all right
so looks like everyone's clear on the
opening front
so Bishop H5 G4 Bishop G6 D3 which I
think is a good move of course like G5
is the move that we had to Oh Black is a
brilliant response here I will admit I
use the engine black has a brilliant
response to G5 and I know this idea this
is an idea that I can even show you a
game that I played to help you find this
move
this is a type of idea that I've seen
also in many openings where basically a
pawn moves past a certain square and it
opens up like an incredibly nasty pin
against that square here's an example of
a game that I played where that exact
thing happened Okay so
I was playing white in a rui Lopez
and I was much better but then my
opponent hastens his defeat
so in this position okay white is
fantastic position but the game
continues but my opponent makes a losing
move he plays a very positionally
sensible move before the idea is to
carve out the D4 Square for his Knight
what does black Miss
what is black Miss here and this move
just escaped his attention
not Knight H5 come on guys 9h5 just GH
op A4 yes Bishop A4 ends the game
because the Knight is pinned there's no
Pawn defending the Knight that's one of
the ways to assess whether a pin is
dangerous and if black defends then he
loses the other Knight which is also
pinned that's it Bishop A4 he played he
actually did play Queen D7 and he
resigned two moves later actually Bishop
B3 is the game-winning move because now
The Rook is lost because the queen is
unoffended
um so it's the same exact concept just
taken to a more tactical level let's go
back to the game
in this position what's the best move
people now have to see it let's see if
my teaching will produce the right
result Bishop H5 is winning for black
Bishop H5 so the point is after GF
actually it's very important to play GF
here why is it important to play GF and
I have another example that perfectly
illustrates this type of concept here of
course GF should be a no-brainer to most
tactical players because it opens up the
G file right Bishop F6 would be terrible
because it would allow white to deliver
a check on E1 and take on D5 with
interest GF keeps the black king safe so
let's say white plays Knight D5 okay
here Knight D4 just ends the game
immediately
probably white should play Bishop D5 but
now you go Rook G8 check if the King
goes up to H2 you can push it back with
Bishop D6 so this is the only sensible
move and now very very simple Pawn on H3
is a huge weakness so what's interesting
is you use this pin as a way to paralyze
white you don't win because of the pin
only you win also because of the
weakness of White's King
and white can't defend the H3 Pawn at
all
because white can't move the Knight and
a fight brings the king up go back and
it's made
so that's it the engine moves Rook G1
take on H3 and you actually take the
queen
and white collects what does white
collect white collects the rook and if
white collects the other Rook then that
Knight is going to get sizzled with
Bishop D6 that's it Queen takes H2
Unstoppable checkmate
so spicy lines here Bishop H5 was the
winning why did that it that went over
my head I didn't see Bishop H5 I
actually I saw a similar type of example
recent let me see if I can find it and
set it up quickly for the folks on
YouTube this is from a doretsky book and
I was like my mind is blown by this
example just a moment
assistant book called chess tests which
I can recommend to people looking for
super high level
training
I mean this is these are very high level
exercises
okay this is a cool position to think
about if you're watching on YouTube I
highly highly recommend that you pause
and give yourself like a minute or two
to think about the position I'm about to
project on the screen
because it really will help develop
your Tactical thinking Okay so
it's this position
and it is black to play in this position
and black is able to win this game with
a remarkable idea I mean this idea is
just freaking amazing
but what do we see when we look at this
position well what we see
is that the Knight on F3 is subject to a
very dangerous pin
okay so well that's obvious but the
problem is you can't exploit the pin
right away you want to play this move
but you can't because GH now most of you
are already saying that F4 what does
that do well not as much as you would
like for it to do because what's the big
problem you don't have a third piece
that you can use to apply pressure on
this Knight if you could just blow on
this Knight it would fall over but you
just don't have that last piece why in
the meantime can start bringing in the
reserves so for instance if I could make
this move and try to get the Knight
around to D2 and then the Knight on F3
is suddenly reinforced so there is an
idea
that allows black to involve another
piece
let's see who can who can find it it's
Rook G8 alph chess got it it's Rook G8
and no matter what white does white is
no moves because this move walks into a
fork everybody should have seen that
that's why white is no threat let's say
white makes a move like Knight B1
now you can play either Knight H4 but
even better splay Knight H4
GH and G5 this is the idea of Rook G8
and black winds and black wins because
white is busted after HG Rook takes G5
check wins the queen
obviously if the king moves then it's
mate if Knight G5 then just Bishop takes
E2
and the game is over there's just
nothing that white can do after Rook G8
at all let's see how the game continued
I I don't remember
what game this is from
oh it's saying oh it's saying it doesn't
find maybe this is a training position
actually Rook G8 Knight B1 Knight H4
ghg5 if white ignores with Knight B to
D2 I think the powerful move here is
actually G4
G4
because you're threatening to take the
Knight and if white takes you take with
a rook and you're just massacring white
on the king's side King H1 Rook takes H4
then white can never move the Knight
King G2 Queen G7 and its check Maiden on
the next move
so such an amazing move just shows you
how powerful pins are and they're
particularly powerful of course when the
pinned piece is not protected by a plot
okay back we go to the to the speedrun
game sorry for the long detour
but hopefully these examples were
semi-illuminating so our opponent
demonstrated good intuition and I think
so did we because now H6 is necessary
here if we Castle we for we have
forfeited the opportunity to play Bishop
H5 it's not the same anymore although
computer still gives equality here which
just tells you how powerful this pin is
but here we don't have the same attack
on White's King
so some of you are asking can white play
G5 here anyway yes but then the H3 Pawn
is going to be caught Under Fire so like
this position is horrible because if a
rook takes H3 and whites King is just in
shambles
yeah ppv is right so Ricky one is
sensible by Urban and I think black is
slightly better here slightly but not
that much Bishop F4 and we improve our
position with Queen to D7
so on second thought I think Queen D7
might actually be a serious inaccuracy
who can remind me what the main drawback
of the move Queen D7 was there was one
major drawback of this movement I think
I underestimated it what move does it
sort of encourage
yeah 95 with Tempo exactly
and the reason that this is annoying for
black what is the reason that this trade
causes problems to Black well it the
pawn on D5 is now under serious fire
white is threatening to take on F6 and
take on D5 right so somehow in my mind I
didn't think this was a dangerous
position but now I think it is and we
might have to play D4 but now the Knight
goes back to E2 and again Knight F4 is a
very nasty follow-up of although we
could play Knight D5 and try to beat
white to the punch but I think white
still plays Knight F4
and I don't love Black's position I
honestly think white is probably for
Choice here this bishop is good the
Queen's coming out to F3 there's a lot
of weak squares in the center
so maybe there's an alternative here
maybe a cold-blooded move like Rook a to
d8 is good
but after Bishop F6 Bishop F6 95 white
gets a big initiative
and if we take this Pawn white goes
rugby one
and if you just eat up all the pawns
you're gonna get screwed on the seventh
ring rookie seven is very strong
Queen B6 now apparently yeah Rook B
takes B7 and white gets the Piggies on
the seventh Black's Bishops are suddenly
all over the place and doing absolutely
nothing
so I think Queen D7 by Me was a very
sloppy move that could have been
punished according to the engine best
would have been to actually play the
move that we it it I mentioned this even
to play Bishop D6 and try to neutralize
White's Bishop on F4 of course white
would have kept the tension with Queen
to D4 and now something like Rook to see
it just sort of improving our position
would have led to perhaps a slightly
better position for black
okay
I'll chest has a question in the line
that we were just analyzing
what happens if we play Bishop D4
Rookie's all beautiful idea you Alps is
on fire here there is this idea
and what happens if y takes on B7 there
is a check on G3
and black takes everything on the king's
side unfortunately white is under no
obligation to take on B7 and I think
white plays this move
defending the G3 square and black is
still in trouble you're right this is
the top computer move
yeah and I mean just look at White's
pieces right White's pieces are just
super super active here
and black is losing some pawns on the
queen side so it's it's a nasty position
so a very instructive moment Queen D7
could have been punished but our
opponent made a very slow move and I
think already after we play Rook 88
maybe white should still play Knight E5
but of course this is not quite as
dangerous with more beef on the D5 Pawn
but still I think 95 would have been
best 92 I think is already the beginning
of you know a step in the wrong
direction perhaps so now we drop our
Bishop back to H7 taking the sting out
of the Moon Knight F4 and now B5 the
most important move of the game this is
where the game was won actually this B5
C4 idea neutralizes the bishop and
really unties our hands
so that we can act in the center
yeah so B5 is is an instructive move
everybody should kind of understand it
just driving in a wedge in order to
greatly restrict the mobility
uh greatly restrict the mobility of the
bishop
and just remember that you can use your
Pawns in order to
change the course of the game by
restricting your opponent's pieces just
the concept of restriction in chess is
super underrated super important there's
a game that I always show as an
introduction to the sort of Art
of restriction and how much it can
change the course of the game which is
an old steinits game
and I'll just show the the critical
moment from that game okay so this is
English against steinits don't expect
anything
extraordinary it's black to play here
how did steinits use his pawns to
massively restrict the mobility of
White's minor pieces
yeah a very simple idea right very very
simple you start with B6 and then you
push the pawn up to C5 and that's it why
it's not as restricted completely so is
White's bishop and White's just gasping
for air but Steines didn't stop there
because a little bit later in the game
and notice how he's like grabbing space
on the king side
and he's keeping the tension in this
position he didn't just stop there
restriction is an intermediate step then
you want to actually push the pieces off
the board but there is a move here that
would be really really bad positionally
and then there's the right approach what
did steinants do here
very nice so here you exploit a typical
idea when the Knight is on B3 you can
chase it away with your corner Pawn A5
and then A4 and white is already gasping
for and Bishop C4 dominating the Knight
on C1 and steinens went on to win
do not play C4 be very careful about
pawn moves in general because it oh it
gives away this massive outpost on D4
and that defeats the purpose of
everything that black has just done
okay and if you thought C4 it's okay
right this is where you want to make
those mistakes right in the training
phase okay back to the game
so I really want to get to the sort of
calculation part of the game so after B5
I think black is clearly better Queen D2
and we drive the pawn in to C4 and I'm
actually really happy with the move
Queen C8 I think this move
is one of the key cogs in our machine
because that opened up the doors to 94
which I will admit I did not see the
idea of Knight E4 when I played Queen C8
the idea only occurred to me after he
played rookie 2.
because and it is the the top engine
move because the Rook on D1 has lost its
Defender
it's just one of those GM moves but try
to unpack what makes it a quote-unquote
GM move well there's two elements to it
or maybe even three the first is that
it's a retreating move and I think some
people subconsciously assign a lower
value to retreating moves which you
shouldn't do by the way the second is
that it keeps the status quo and that's
another thing which makes people
uncomfortable when the position is
complex so key takeaway from this game
is that when you get a complicated
position with a lot going on if there
are no direct threats it doesn't mean
that you can't make General improving
moves right you can be the one to keep
the tension how does Queen seed improve
the position well I didn't like the
relationship between the Queens here and
by dropping the queen back you're first
of all taking the sting out of the move
Knight E5 which earlier could have
caused a lot of problems and second of
all opening up an x-ray against whites
Queen so that if white ever plays DC we
can basically recapture with tempo
okay so Queen C8 rookie two now you just
have to spot the tactics Knight E4
and here's what I was talking about
during the game finally the moment has
arrived after d-e-d-e there's an easy
line and there's a hard line the easy
line is White Moving the queen back here
well you can just play EF okay
and that's it Rook d a queen d a black
is up a pawn and the Knights coming to
you but this is
self-evidently bad for a way
but the move that caused me some
problems is Knight to T5
and here's the problem if you play EF
white has Rook takes C7 not Knight E7
this loses because the queen is hanging
in the Rook isang but instead white
plays Rook takes C7 and if you play 97
this is the line I mentioned Knight C8
blah blah blah at the end you're down
two Bishops to one
okay
so I had to figure out a move in this
position who can remind me of the idea
that I came up with this is the critical
idea without which this whole line would
have failed what are we talking about
Rogue D5 excellent you guys have been
paying attention followed by Rook d8 how
did I see this well
anytime you have a complex position
every move you have to update your board
State you basically have to say Okay
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
this move tactically and a sub question
in that umbrella is what pieces does it
leave undefended so the moment rookie to
happen I noticed that the Rook on D1 is
now pretty dangerously poorly defended
especially because we have a rook
staring right down the barrel of the
queen so once you notice that I think
it's easier to find 94 and in particular
it's much easier to find Rook D5 because
with the white Rook still on E1 this
obviously would have failed
now white has to give up the queen and
clearly black should be winning here
because White's pieces are terrible and
the game continues but it's minus two or
so
okay
instead our opponent refrained from
taking
apparently here I missed
oh I missed a sick idea oh my god dude
computers are ridiculous do you want to
see what I missed this is an impossible
move which human would not take the
bishop oh my God there's a retreating
move here that's wild
so Knight G3 is what I played the top
engine move is Knight G5
so you're like I don't get it like okay
so what if white just takes on G5 the
point is by moving the Knight off of F3
you're opening up access to the D4
Square by opening up access to the D4
Square you're opening up access to the
rook and the F3 Square so what's the
idea you take back with the pawn and
white has to spend a Tempo moving the
Knight and bang knight T4 wins the game
because rookie 7 Knight F3 loses the
queen and rookie three Knight C2 loses
The Rook
so after Knight G5 apparently in this
position white has to give away an
exchange with rookie seven
GF Bishop F4 97 Queen E7 but clearly
black is winning here up in exchange the
rook's coming into E2 sick
Savage computer idea Knight G5 how do
you find this I guess the only way would
be if you had directly noticed that the
D4 square is a massive Outpost here
and if you paid proper attention to the
forkable nature of the queen and the
King but still night night retreating
moves are the most difficult type of
move in chess the retreating night moves
and here you can see why instead we took
and give black a white bit of a new
lease on life
okay so D4 I think exact I think D4 is a
very serious mistake our opponent loses
his patience and ultimately just cannot
keep the tension any longer now first of
all 95 Bishop C5 is of course the
tactical side of what I just did because
if the Knight blocks then you can just
take twice on D3 and white collapses
so D4 is is a very bad move because it
opens up the diagonal for the bishop
mainly it grants us this massive Square
on e4
and it just relinquishes all of White's
counter play it basically buries this
bishop once and for all
what should white have done well
probably some random move to keep the
tension the engine suggests King G2
right one of those moves that just like
you just play it to toss the ball back
into your opponent's side of the chord
and it's hard actually hard for black to
improve this position probably we would
have dropped the bishop back to C7
because now Knight takes D5 is already a
threat again update the board State what
does King G2 do oh Bishop C5 is no
longer a check oh I need to defend the
D5 Pawn so Bishop C7
and black is much better we can play A5
before we can play Queen to B8 on the
next move and harass the Knight as we
did in the game but the game would have
continued still very very unpleasant so
D4 Queen B8 windy two Bishop E4 is
already the beginning of the end and it
doesn't take very long for white to
collapse Rook fe8 improving improving
C3 and bang going after the queen side
not letting white breathe at all I would
say
that in this position white can keep his
cool at least keep himself in the game
by protecting the bishop on B1 I think
White's only move in this position would
have been Rook ff1 which is a very
difficult move for most players because
it's hard to figure out what's going on
in this position
maybe also just taking on B4 and then
going Rook ff1 would have been even
slightly more accurate
because here after BC you can safely
play BC and the bishop on B1 is
protected
so what would we have done in this
position well probably we would have
doubled Rooks on the E file
so we would have played a move like
rookie seven
and then Rook de-8 but the thing is
white can already take on e4
because after de there's no Fork threat
and the engine somehow
wow E3 Queen E2 you can actually play G5
and Fork the knights but white gets some
active counter play here black is
winning but white gets some practically
active counter play
so these are like Minor Details as to
how our opponent could have stayed in
the game longer the bigger broader
picture is that by this point white is
under
massive practical strain and it's not a
surprise that our opponent just focused
on the wrong thing and forgot about the
queen side and ba wins the game because
here we simply take the bishop and
that's a free bishop and that's it
Bishop before d e hastens defeat but why
does no moves here white has literally
no moves here
like if white plays I don't know rookie
too then we can even play
we can play very simple we can just
simplify takes takes takes and just play
a B I mean and then Queen to B3 because
the C3 Pawn is ridiculously weak yeah so
this this A5 B4 was really the decisive
idea because it it really takes it to
White on the queen side and it was
important to notice that this is losing
for white because of the threat of e3 so
there are always these tactical
components to the positional play
so after King G2 ba takes takes we take
we play E3 and we convert this as
accurately as possible 95 Bishop F2 and
our opponent resigned because I'm
tricking F2 we can just win the queen
this way or this way
okay and that concludes the analysis any
questions
what happens after white goes a takes B4
and then trades Bishops so try to be a
little bit more specific oh a takes
before
here well again white can never trade
Bishops because of the threat of E3
was rookie 3 any good again I'm not
totally sure where
rookie three here maybe rookie three no
because here we take twice on F4 and
whites blocks this control over that
square
Barry beats asked in the opening after
Pawn pushed to D3
so after the pawn pushed to D3 what if
C4 is played well if black plays C4 then
white can just take the pawn you don't
have enough Firepower to
shove this move through
um would A4 be a blunder instead of B4
the idea to close that side and control
the center yes that would be a very bad
move what you're talking about is A4 in
this position would be not a terrible
move but who is better on the queen side
is the question you want to ask yourself
it's black it's not about we can still
focus on the center we're not exerting
that many resources toward
attacking on the queen side we're just
opening up another front where we're
better
what components did you consider when
playing Queen C8
um
so I guess first and foremost I decided
on the category of move that I was gonna
play I decided that I wasn't going to do
anything drastic such as G5 and that
opened up my eyes to ways to improve my
position so like the first move I was
going to play as Rick f8 which by the
way would be a good move so don't like
over
worry if you didn't see Queen C8 because
it moves like Rook fe8 or even like A5
are probably very decent
but but mainly I was just tired of the
queen stumbling under my own pieces and
I wanted it on sort of the back burner
here supporting
supporting the battle from a distance I
wrote a chest.com article called Queen
the supporting actress which is all
about basically how to use your queen in
attacking
and I will conclude with one
illustrative game
where in order to convert the attack you
do something
ridiculously counter-intuitive
and this is directly
related
so what we're talking about here with
the use of the queen particularly when
you're attacking can be super
counter-intuitive the the concept itself
comes from yester who taught it to me
you always would refer to the queen as a
supporting actress okay so this is a
game that I played or not as an I am I
beat a GM in this game
so in this position I played this wild
move Rook D7 this is the most typical
narrative scheme of ever Rook D7 Queen
G4 picks up the Rook because of the main
thread on G7
and I got this big attack
and I kept moseying around with my queen
and eventually
we got
this position
okay so we got this position
okay so why does attacking obviously and
it may seem self-evident that the queen
on H6 is the is the best place piece on
the board right that Queen is amazing
and so I think if you think in general
terms you'll probably come up with the
move H4 right this is probably what
people might be thinking the problem
with H4 is that it's way too slow and
black generates massive counter play by
sticking the bishop on e4
because suddenly though this is hanging
and if you have to play this move well
what are you gonna attack with because
even if I let you play H5 and then I let
you play HG big deal black is just going
to take back with the bishop and there's
no
you can't attack but Don brilliant's got
The Right Move I I realized that in
order for the attack to succeed I will
have to involve the Knight I have to
involve the Knight otherwise with the
rook and the queen you can't break
through how can we involve the Knight
well I thought maybe like Knight D2 but
where is the Knight going from here it
can never reach F3 because it'll be
captured
so I thought well maybe the night I'd
see one but Knight C1 black still plays
Bishop B4 and picks picks the Knight off
before it reaches anywhere good so the
solution is Queen E3 you use the queen
in order to pave the way for the Knight
to jump into C5
and using the fact that Black's Queen is
permanently tied down because black
cannot allow F7 that would be a disaster
so black plays H6 trying to lure my
queen back so that he could play Bishop
E4 but no I focus on eyes on the prize
Knight C5
but why are we putting the Knight on C5
where is it actually going it's not
going to C5
we are not trying to take the bishop
we are dropping it back to D3
why are we dropping it back to D3 so
that we could then put it on E5
why are we putting it on E5 well now the
queen has been chased away and here
there is simply a winning move which
falls in a category that I mentioned can
be hard to find but why to play and end
the game
notice that Queen takes C2 is not a
dangerous threat because you can simply
move the king to the side to A1
so what's the winning move here
it's not F7 it's not F7
because here maybe black is still
kicking after King G7
it's not Knight takes G6
it is Knight to G4
retreating Night Moves
you're attacking H6
so black takes the pawn
and the only way for black to defend H6
notice that this sorry this is not
possible this is also not possible
because the Knight also defends H2 black
has to go here and now Queen H3 and he
resigned
because that's it H6 cannot be defended
and it's Checkmate after the queen takes
on H6
so Queen is the supporting actress you
actually drop the queen back to E3 using
it to kind of direct traffic from your
side of the board which is another I
think interesting takeaway from this
game
and that is how we will conclude folks I
will be on chess base India
in an hour from now so I'll be staying
up tonight
um I will be talking about the jibava
course which is
selling incredibly well we are over 200
people
so a massive thank you 211 actually a
massive thank you to everybody who has
gotten the course and I hope you're
enjoying it yeah this is exceeding our
our wildest expectations hopefully we
can get to a couple thousand
okay thank you everybody
[Music]